as a man who has dedicated his life to
thinking about fashion and style i'm
sure that you're familiar with the
recent new york times article redefining
what hotness means saying that hotness
is no longer in the eye of the beholder
it's a mood it's a vibe a social media
movement inspired by the rapper megan
the stallion strikes back at the
gatekeepers of beauty do you see this
i am not familiar with this at all but
maybe it's because i don't go out my way
to find fashion articles wow that
surprises me so many people many people
are expanding the definition of hotness
taking it beyond its former association
with old notions of attractiveness these
days being hot no longer pertains to
only your physical appearance but
includes how you move through the world
and how you see yourself many of those
pushing for a broader understanding of
the term are also pushing back against
the idea that you need to wait for
confirmation from someone else before
feeling justified in calling yourself
hot to them hotness is a
self-declaration and that's that hotness
is no longer in the eye of the beholder
it's a mood it's a vibe emily sundberg
28 year old editor and filmmaker in
brooklyn was eating spaghetti when she
had a realization she was hot there was
nothing glamorous about it it was just a
solo weeknight dinner in the kitchen
counter and ms sundberg was wearing
workout clothes and glasses but she felt
moved to make a video of herself as she
twirled past her strands on a fork and
succeeded succeeded in getting most of
them all the way into her mouth as she
chewed with kanye west's jail blaring in
the background she stared into the lens
with a blank expression so this is
hotness in zoomer generation
what's the sexuality the sexual
orientation where you're attracted to
people because of what the way they
think
their brain is
it's something like
scopiosexual or yeah yes sapiosexual say
piosexual there we go sapiosexual
oh my god um yeah i d i wasn't familiar
with this article but you know
it's i guess it's fitting into this this
whole movement's obsession with the way
that beauty is uh is not a thing beauty
is a sort of a a patriarchal western
construct and um therefore anything can
be beautiful but the thing is some
things just aren't
i've seen the video of her twirling her
noodles or pasta or whatever it is into
her mouth
i've seen it done better it's first off
it's not the thing that i think of in
the top echelons of hotness and i've
seen it done better but
you don't have to ask for permission to
be hot online ms sunberg said there's
not one thing that defines what hot is
it's confidence it's the way you dress
it's the way you present yourself to
other people you don't get to decide
whether you're hot well for one thing it
is subjective let's be honest people are
attracted to different types you know
some people are attracted to
you know skinny people some people
attracted to fat people something you
know that you know blondes brunettes
whatever it that's true
um but you don't get to decide that
you're attractive as a kind of label
right i got you can i not self-identify
as hot
i wouldn't have thought so because
to whom
you know doesn't it depend
what if someone's you know someone who's
uh like you won't be hot
to a lesbian will you
well maybe that's their prejudice
showing well if you were the head of
stonewall that's exactly what you would
think
ah yeah you had to run in with them
you're not am i well i mean just
generally you're always unhappy with
them no it's not i'm not well no i am
unhappy with them because i think you
know it's it's such a shame that an
important gay rights group in the uk is
now uh promoting anti-gay ideas so yeah
that makes me a bit sad um nancy kelly
the ceo of stonewall describe women
women lesbians who want who don't want
to have sex with people with penises who
identify as women but are male she
described them as sexual racists i think
that's a problem she compared them to
anti-semites
uh
i think we used to call that kind of
phrase uh homophobic didn't we
so yeah i do and my issue with stonewall
you know quite apart from all the other
things is that i invite them onto my
show constantly all the time
and they just never say yes because they
say we don't have debate
but i want to ask them about their
policies i want to ask them why they
changed the definition of homosexual on
their website and their promotional
materials to same gender attracted which
is not what it means i mean same sex
attracted because gay men aren't
attracted to people who identify as men
they're attracted to men it's very much
about the penis with gay men in my
sort of tangential understanding of what
gay men like it's very much about us
don't pretend that's tangential you've
done some research
clearly you've done it's about the penis
and not just the
penis plasti it's about the
yeah i mean well that's clearly an
element and
the i
you know i get that that there's more to
uh same-sex attraction than genitals
that's absolutely true
but but you're
you can't feign sexual attraction and
you can't relearn
uh your innate
sexual orientation which is what they're
kind of implying what nancy kelly is
saying in stonewall is what the
homophobes used to say to gay men you
know you just haven't found the right
girl yet you know you need to open your
mind a little bit more you need to you
know all of that stuff it's just
recycled ancient tropes it's really it's
so sad are they saying you haven't found
the right trans man yet
uh well they're suggesting that if you
if you close off
certain demographics from your dating
pool then that's the result of bigotry
but of course everyone does that
everyone does that in one way or another
because everyone has
a type someone that they are types of
people that they're attracted to and
sure sometimes there can be people from
other categories that surprise you or
what whatever sexuality is complicated
but the idea that if you're not
attracted to a certain type of person
you need to relearn that and examine
your own bigotry and prejudice it's just
it's just homophobia dressed up as
something else that's all it's also
happening elsewhere right so if you can
see how this hotness discussion would
slowly encroach onto
some sort of bigotry men that don't date
bigger women would be sizes
interestingly you don't see as much
about women dating short men there's not
really as much criticism for women for
doing no if you've got some five foot
five guy and he's saying well why is it
that women shouldn't date me if i have
to date fat girls
doesn't seem
you have a right to be to be attractive
to be considered attractive and you have
a right to go out with someone like
someone says no isn't that the end of
the conversation
no i don't know maybe not anymore so
this sunderberg lady finished up here
and she said that doesn't need that
doesn't mean that you have to be the
most symmetrically physically perfect
human being i feel like that isn't even
as desirable anymore our definition of
attraction and attractiveness has
expanded so much well your publicly
stated preferences have but your
revealed preferences something would
tell me is going to end up with you not
sleeping with the homeless guy on the
street that doesn't have a job and only
has like two teeth
yeah quite exactly this person's a
hypocrite right i i missed this article
i don't know how i missed it did this go
viral i normally get sent this nonsense
because when i i normally because my job
now every day you know i get up in the
morning and i i uh i search for this
stuff or people send me this stuff
because i obviously have to collect
material for my show on the sunday
um so i don't normally miss snook
underneath the radar what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]